no dad we just finished our song the  other day so it mean Tim and I a few  comments I think it's it's okay I like  hearing that  yes good again it's you know don't  expect an episodic piece it's difficult  when you're gonna make a two-hour movie  of an episodic TV so there's a little  bit but I think they got the setting  right they got the links right on they  got everybody back which is really great  because they could have made you know 7l  ride the high country together that  wouldn't have been dead bird that would  just be me and Tim sort of catching  enough this is milk Deadwood yeah  circa 10 years later statehood  difficulty characters have moved on  their little change which is great  should be  you